-Welcome to the show.
We were just talking backstage.
We've met a couple of times
because you hosted "SNL" and --
or you didn't host,
but you were a musical guest
in 2010 and 2011.
You don't do a lot of
talking on talk shows?
-No, I get really nervous
and I get quite shy, so, yeah.
-All right.
-I get a bit scared,
but I'm gonna try.
-Okay. Good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, one thing you did -- Yeah.
[ Applause ]
And this wasn't unique
to this show.
I guess you do this
all the time.
But I went to the dressing room
to say hello before the show.
It's the same dressing room
every night.
It doesn't look any different,
except tonight when I walked in,
you had completely redecorated.
[ Laughter ]
There were a lot of scarves.
-I think I moved the mirror
around a bit.
And yeah, I have --
you know, I have quite
a strong sense of aesthetic.
I don't know
if that comes across.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
When you walk into a room
that no one has touched
and you've completely rearranged
it, it came across.
[ Laughter ]
-Some people say it's obsessive,
but I'm working on it.
-Obsessive would be, if I called
you after you left and was like,
"You didn't put it back
exactly right."
-But it looks better.
-Well, it -- Okay.
It looks a little better, yeah.
But that's something you do
when you are on tour?
-Yeah.
I mean, we bring -- well, yeah.
I bring -- I kind of
collect throws and --
there's lots of patterns
and embroidery and, kind of --
but it's also a nice thing to do
when you arrive and, you know,
I spend, like, a good
half an hour just kind of
decorating and something.
-Can you go over to friends'
houses and leave it alone?
-It's hard, no.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I stay at home a lot.
I wish that was a joke.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you, obviously, you can't
stay home all the time
because you're going out
on tour.
Australia, New Zealand -- you
are coming here to the States.
You're doing the Barclays.
-Yes.
-So, do you like the road?
Do you like the big shows?
-The shows are kind of --
it's just so important to me.
It's where everything
comes together.
I don't know.
It's kind of, like,
how I make sense of myself,
in a way.
But also, I feel kind of -- I've
been doing it for a while,
and I feel kind of
really honored,
'cause sometimes
you really get to see
the best in people at a show.
-Sure.
-Like, you -- I mean, I
literally, I'm up there like,
"Everybody, tell each other
that you love each other.
Tell people you don't know
you love each other."
And you just see everybody,
they're so up for it.
And, yeah.
So, it -- it, kind of -- it's so
important to me,
the live aspect and connection
is such a big part of that.
And when you feel you're taking
everyone somewhere with you.
It's a very collaborative thing,
I think, a gig.
-And it must be nice, obviously,
to now be known.
You know, I'm sure
in your early gigs,
people didn't know who you were,
and if you told them to go tell
each other they love each other,
they're like, "That weird lady
is being very bossy."
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
I was very drunk most of these.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I was definitely
still being bossy.
I don't think I minded
if people didn't do it.
-Oh, that's cute.
But this is -- very early on,
you knew you wanted to
be a performer.
This is not something
you came to late in life.
I've heard --
I should say I've read that
when you were 8 years old,
you would put on your mom's
robes and sing Billie Holiday
with a wine glass
full of orange juice.
[ Laughter ]
So, you -- you were, what, like,
you wanted all of rock music
early on.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
I was like, "I know
what I'm gonna be,
and it involves drinking
and being sad."
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, I went there.
-Yeah.
You know, it's nice when
an 8-year-old finds their dream.
-I was, like, 8 and I knew that
it would involve a wine glass.
-Oh, my God.
Also, as an 8-year-old,
being like,
"Billie Holiday --
That's someone who gets me."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Billie Holiday, like,
Etta James, Nina Simone,
you know, those were --
those were the first voices
that I was really drawn to.
-That's fantastic.
I always, I remember, you know,
the first time I heard you sing,
and I also remember hearing
the band name and being like,
"Wow. Florence and the Machine,
that's a fantastic band name."
It was not your first band.
But it maybe was
your first good band name.
What was your first band?
-My first band was at school.
And I was 11,
and I had a punk band called
The Toxic Cockroaches.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-But we only had a drum kit.
I was the guitarist,
but I didn't have a guitar.
And the only instrument
we had was a drum kit.
-Okay, so, what does a guitarist
without a guitar hold?
-[ Laughs ]
Not much.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, not much.
I held a lot of enthusiasm.
-Oh, that's good. Yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That comes across today.